(rock, hip hop music)
- We're in Chicago, this
is a big fighter town.
- Cohen, you're
a great sport for
fucking letting us--
- Oh fuck off.
- These guys have chips
on their shoulders.
- And Dillinger got
shot right over there
and Roast Battle's getting
shot right over here.
- Already looks like Jake Cutler
yelling at one of his linemen.
(audience laughs)
- It's gonna be a bloodbath.
This is gonna be Rocky one.
(bell rings)
- The only the reason why
I feel bad beating you
cause I'm a Southern white
male and it frankly is cliche.
(audience laughs)
- This is like Patrice
versus O'Neill.
(audience screams)
- You've got the Sklar
Brothers, we love those guys.
We call them everybody's
favorite nobodys.
Because they're known
in the comedy community
but nowhere else.
- A man, when you
were born, was it
vaginal, cesarean, or you
just eat your way out?
(audience laughs)
- I would drink with you
just so you talk about me
then I'll slap the
shit outta you, dude.
- Lil Rel on The
Carmichael Show on NBC,
he's a funny dude from Chicago
and it's good to have
that kind of flavor here,
a local guy.
(gun shoots)
- I'm just happy to be roasting
somebody with the same
size titties as I got.
(audience laughs)
- I know I'mma take a
lot of shit personal
so I wrote a lot
of personal shit.
- I know it's tough
being a woman in comedy.
You have to go through
a lot of stuff.
Luckily, you never had to
worry about being raped
by Bill Cosby cause they
can't deep fry a rufi.
(audience gasps)
- Deep fried rufi?
- Depp fried rufi joke, I
thought that was hysterical.
- The deep fried rufi joke?
I was like oh you fat fuck,
why didn't I think of that?
(laughs)
- John likes to compare
himself to George Carlin
because of his
storytelling abilities.
I like to compare him to Carlin
because of his alcoholism
and because I wish
he were fucking dead.
(audience screams)
- I really want
Colin to win just so
Moses can try to raise
that hand in the air.
(laughs)
- You gotta really be
able to take a joke
to live in this town.
Pretty psyched for Roast
Battle Chicago tonight.